MATT BALDWIN: So
I'm Matt Baldwin.
I'm the director of cloud native
engineering here at NetApp,
and I'm here today to talk to
you about NetApp's cloud data
services strategy,
and how we're trying
to simplify enterprise
multi-cloud deployments
of cloud native infrastructure
and cloud native workload.
We build this on top of
six different pillars
that we've defined in
our product, which is--
the first is how do
we simplify enterprise
multi-cloud Kubernetes?
And what we mean by that is,
what we're trying to arrive at
is, that you do not have to
worry about the cloud provider
that you're building
your cluster on top of,
that you're managing
infrastructure on top of,
that the experience
matches the same.
So if you're using
Google, that experience
is the same as Amazon, as
is the same for on premise.
And that's what we're trying
to do with our enterprise
multi-cloud Kubernetes offering.
Our second pillar is
application management.
And we're trying to follow the
same theme there, which is to--
how do you simplify the
developer experience
with building, shipping, and
running applications inside
of Kubernetes?
How do you ensure those
applications can scale?
How do you automate that?
How do you scale them
across multiple providers?
How do you scale
them from on-prem
to off prem, in a
hybrid scenario?
And that is what we're
driving out with application
management-- essentially how
do you transform a Kubernetes
cluster into a Heroku-like
experience for the developer?
So they never have to
understand Kubernetes.
They don't need to
know what Istio is.
They can perform a canary.
Not a problem.
The third component
that we stand on top of
is manage data
services and storage.
So NetApp is a storage
company as many people know.
And we have over 20
years of experience
in enterprise grade storage
and delivering solutions out
to consumers and to customers.
And what we're doing
is, we're working
to lift all of those
features into, and pull those
into Kubernetes, so that we
can guarantee your application.
We can protect it.
We can guarantee
IOPS for your app.
We can move your app around
from provider to provider
and the storage will follow you.
Snapshot, mirror,
clone, all that goodness
comes from the NetApp
technology that we're
pulling up into Kubernetes.
And that's one main, one
of the primary pillars
that we're standing on top
of, is that we were able to--
we've solved the stateful
workload problem in Kubernetes
at NetApp.
And that's very important, as
you guys probably all know,
for Kubernetes.
The fourth pillar is
ecosystem integration.
What we mean there is we don't
mean just taking Helm charts
and throwing them into a
bucket of a marketplace,
and then letting the
user figure out what
they need to do with that.
When we're talking
ecosystem integration,
we're talking about deeply
integrating with ecosystem
partners to deliver a value out
to their users, versus being
a feature farm where you're
trying to just iterate through
as many features as possible.
What we're trying to do
is arrive at user value.
So when that user clicks
up and slides that slider,
enables that feature, that
they immediately have value
that they can consume.
And we have a
partner that we can
bring on stage here
in a bit, to talk
about that, that type of
ecosystem integration.
The fifth item is,
again, we're trying
to build simple tooling
for developers, operators,
and SREs.
As our SRE teams figure
out and solve issues,
we're pushing those
feature sets, those types
of dashboards, down
to the end users,
so those users can
use those things.
The sixth pillar for
us is channel partners.
So our product actually
enables you to rebrand.
Anyone can launch their
own Kubernetes service.
We can partner with anyone.
We have a partner we're
bringing on stage again,
who will show you one
of the partnerships
that we're doing on that.
But it allows us to enable
our enterprise partners
to sell to their
enterprises, and enable that
through the channel.
So we not only go direct, we
also go through the channel.
And that's one of
the big pillars
that we stand on top of.
So why are we here today?
We have four things that
we're going to announce.
First, that we're
working with NVIDIA.
NVIDIA and NetApp
are working together
to deliver an NVIDIA
Kubernetes Services
Product that focuses on deep
learning, AI, ML, and I have--
Adel El Hallak will be coming
on stage to talk about that.
The second item is our cloud
native application management
is going to go to
pre-release, and that's
going to be a bulk
of this presentation.
We're going to show
you what that is.
And I'm going to
have Dan Norris, one
of my senior
engineers, will come
on stage to demo that, and
take you through all that work.
And again, our focus
has always been
to simplify the
experience for the user,
and I think that's going
to come through when
you start to see the
tooling that we've
built for developers.
The third item is,
we've enabled what
we call an NKS enterprise
registry, which
is built on top of--
we've effectively integrated
into the CNC of Harbor Project,
to enable enterprise
registry in public cloud,
and private cloud as well, and
that's all wrapped up inside
of our workflow.
The fourth item is cloud
volume services on GCP,
and that we're going to be
going into beta with that
at the end of May.
And because storage is rather
important to applications.
And so we're going to
conclude today's presentation
with a discussion around cloud
native persistent storage,
and how that relates
to what we're doing.
And I have Alim
coming on to do that.
So first I want
to bring up Adel,
who will talk about our NVIDIA
partnership on Kubernetes.
ADEL EL HALLAK: Thanks, Matt.
Good morning, everyone.
My name's is Adel El Hallak.
I'm director of product
management over at NVIDIA.
I looked after NGC.
So real quick, what is NGC?
NGC is an accelerated
software hub,
some of the most popular
accelerated applications
out there in the marketplace.
We start off with HPC
and visualization,
but actually that bleeds
over into ML and DL,
which is a huge focus of ours.
So it started off as
a container registry,
but we've expanded a lot
more than that since.
We've since introduced
pre-trained models that
are domain specific,
across medical imaging,
or video analytics.
Also some models
that are up there,
just ready for inference.
We've also introduced
model training scripts,
so teaching entities how to
train to state of the art
accuracy and get models how
to converge state of the art
accuracy from scratch, right?
Study exactly what
container to pull where,
where to get your data sets,
what learning rate the set,
and be able to
replicate some of those
[? anchors ?] that we drive.
And again, growing
above and beyond that,
where we really
start deriving value
is when you become domain
specific, industry specific.
So as Matt alluded
to earlier, we
are introducing industry
specific Helm charts,
or workflows, that frankly go
from an end to end perspective.
But why are we here, right?
We realized that
that wasn't enough.
And I love this theme
that Matt's been driving,
which is a simplification
theme, right?
This is a software hub.
It's almost giblets.
The reality is data
science is a team sport.
And often we talk about
the data scientists.
We talk about the developers.
But it takes an array
of different personas
collaborating
together, to realizing
the right value, right?
Wouldn't even talk
about DevOps, systems
admin, IT managers, who have
to worry about auto scaling
or have to worry
about OSs that are
supported in their data centers
or in their respective clouds.
So how do we alleviate
some of those concerns?
And this is why we're partnering
with NetApp on the NKS service.
So real quick, let me
show you, if you don't
mind going through computers.
Let me show you what
NGC is all about.
As I said earlier,
containers across an array
of different industries and
segments come to deep learning
here.
Our engineers, our
data scientists,
optimize against our
GPO accelerations,
optimize TensorFlow.
We upstream those
to the community
through the open source
community, as well.
But we also post those
in [? NGCS ?] containers
on a monthly basis.
As I said earlier, we've
got pre-train models
across an array of couple
of different industries,
and some that are already
ready for inference,
and these model scripts
that I talked about.
Again, really showing you how
to reach a state of the art
accuracy, get your
models to converge,
and be able to build on that.
But as I said earlier,
that's not enough, right?
How do we go from use
case to actually being
able to deploy a prototype?
And so what we're
introducing, and what
we're going to be showing later
on at the booth on the demo is,
if you go back to
the slides, please--
is the ability to deploy a
container or a Helm chart
directly through the NGC portal,
through the NetApp Kubernetes
service.
So as a data scientist
or an ML, doesn't
matter what your
proficiency level
is, to be able to
deploy with a few clicks
onto your favorite cloud service
provider or on-prem seamlessly,
with just a few clicks.
And we're just starting
with inferencing.
Inference is the first use case.
And that's the one we're
going to be demoing over
at the booth at noon.
Again, with just a
few clicks, to be
able to deploy on
a Kubernetes based
cluster, autoscale up and down
and as many nodes as possible,
our inference server,
which can concurrently
run multiple models on a
single GPU or on a single node.
And we're starting
with inferencing,
because we think
that derives value.
This whole notion
is about simplifying
so you guys can derive value.
But we want to
get your feedback.
We want to co-create
with you guys.
In this audience, tell
us is a deep learning,
training workflows that
you want us to focus on?
Is it something specific to
machine learning and our rapids
libraries?
So we're super excited.
This is just the start of
what we're kicking off.
And again we want to
co-create with the audiences.
We want to derive
value, as opposed
to just providing
shelves of software.
So we look forward to
hearing from you guys
as we go along, in terms of
what are some of the use cases
you want to see.
But more importantly, we
hope to see at our booth
later on at noon, where
we're going to be executing
[INAUDIBLE] demo on this.
So without further ado,
let me introduce Dan.
Sorry, we have five speakers.
I'm wasn't sure who
the next one is.
Let me introduce Dan real
quick onto stage, who is going
to talk about app management.
DAN NORRIS: Turns out I
don't actually need that.
Hey everybody.
So I'm pretty excited
to share with you what
we've been working on to kind
of improve the foundation
that we've had with NKS.
So what we have been pretty good
at is delivering Kubernetes,
like a consistent experience
across multiple clouds.
And what we've been working
on-- me and my team--
is basically this
suite of features
that we think of as
application management.
So our goal here is to give
you Kubernetes clusters that
are batteries included,
so to make the developer
experience best in breed
of any product out there.
So what we've been
focusing on are
things like providing a Git
based workflow, so basically
do a Git push sort of workflow,
to be able to actually create
Kubernetes deployments
automatically,
to be able to detect
what type of application
you're actually delivering.
And we've also been looking at
shipping application health,
dashboards, metrics, logging--
pretty much everything
that you would
want as an SRE while actually
going through and delivering
value for your product.
And we're not really standing
in the way here, right?
These are all sort
of opt in additions.
We're implementing them as
Kubernetes custom resources.
So these are things that we are
pre-installing on your cluster,
ready to go, whenever you spin
up a Kubernetes cluster on NKS.
And so, things that
writing on here, too--
quick auto scaling,
resource management,
quota configuration.
We've got a number of
different solution types,
and I'll walk through sort of
what that looks like, as we
get a little bit into the demo.
So what you're going
to see sort of our take
on what we think application
management should look like.
So the way that we think
of it is that applications,
we deploy them into projects.
If you're familiar with
Kubernetes terminology,
a project is basically
an abstraction
around Kubernetes namespaces.
We add a little bit
of magic on top of it,
again through using
custom resources.
And then what we call
solutions are basically
definitions of how you
deploy your application.
It's not just a
deployment, a StatefulSet,
a daemon set, right?
This adds context.
This adds value by
showing how you actually
deliver your application,
how it gets to your cluster.
So a little bit
more about projects.
We think of it as
a container, right?
You want to take everything
that comprises your application.
So perfect example
is, say, WordPress.
You're going to
need MySQL server.
need the WordPress
PHP, and all the other
pages that go to that.
That belongs all in
the same project.
Those might be multiple pods.
You can scale them differently,
doesn't really matter,
because it's still Kubernetes
at the end of the day.
What we add on top of that is,
again, extensions to namespace.
So we hook into, through
our product, RBAC,
so we effectively reflect
that into the clusters,
so that you as a
cluster admin can
take that and restrict
who has access
to these particular resources.
So say your SRE team is
allowed to make changes
to your production applications,
but your developers
are only allowed to read them.
That's what we've kind of
added as on an extension there.
And so in terms of the solutions
that we've come up with,
we kind of targeted three
for our pre-release.
So we have what we
call the tracker.
And the tracker is kind of like
the lowest common denominator
of our solution.
It's basically-- you are
an experienced Kubernetes
developer.
You're experienced at actually
delivering applications
and help the platform.
This is how you
effectively inform
our backend of what that is.
So we can effectively adopt
your application, as is,
to keep your deploy
strategy, and it just works.
Again, if you're familiar
with Kubernetes terminology,
this is effectively
just label selectors.
We use that to adopt an
existing StatefulSet,
and that way you can manage
it through our interface.
And then the next solution that
we have is the Git workflow.
So effectively Git,
push, NKS master.
We want to be able to take
pretty much any application
that you have in any
programming language,
and make it that
simple to deploy,
and get a Kubernetes
deployment out of it.
And the third that we've
got our Helm charts, right?
CNCF going pretty
hard on actually
having Helm charts be sort of
the package management solution
for Kubernetes.
So we want to support that.
So all we really need know is
where does your chart live,
and what changes do you want to
make to its values.yaml which
is how you configure it.
And we effectively
take care of the rest.
We deploy it, we
manage the lifecycle,
and we do this actually--
again, if you're kind of
familiar with the way that
Helm kind of works, it's a
client server application.
So we do it without
the server component.
Because we've written custom
code and extensions on top
of your Kubernetes
cluster, we're
able to actually lock
that down, giving you
a much more secure way to
actually deliver Helm charts.
And so now for the demo,
we're going to do this live,
so we'll see how this goes.
Where is-- there we go.
So let me just get
to this screen.
Bouncing around, sorry.
So what we have is basically
a multi-cloud solution
for deploying
Kubernetes clusters.
So what I have here, I
have two different clusters
that are deployed on GCP, all
with random names, by the way,
I didn't make any of these up.
So Spring Mouse
and Young Forest.
The former is a
three node cluster.
The latter is a seven node
cluster, all in us-west1.
We've got an AWS
cluster, and we've
got a Azure cluster as well.
And so in each of these clusters
we pre-configure a enterprise
registry.
So this registry, because
it's based on Harbor,
allows us to manage both Docker
images for your projects,
and also Helm charts.
So we'll go to Young Forest
and see what's on here.
And so I've gone ahead and
pushed a number of images here.
We've got Alpine, we've got
Cassandra, we've got Ubuntu,
and then we've got a
couple Helm charts.
And we can go through and we
can see, and subdivide by class,
right?
So we've got a couple
of charts here--
Envoy and Prometheus.
We've got a registry token
that we use for authentication.
And to show that this actually
works, we're going to re-tag--
latest, if I could type.
So this is just the
upstream nginx image.
I'm just going to push it
straight to the cluster.
And here we go.
So this is just pushing the
image straight up the cluster.
It should show up as
soon as this is done.
Thank you, conference
Wi-Fi for cooperating.
We have to refresh the page.
I'm impatient.
Sorry.
So, not sure why
it didn't pop up.
OK.
Welcome to the joy
of doing live demos.
So that's our enterprise
registry offering.
And so the other concept I
wanted to introduce you to
is the project concept.
So projects-- effectively,
you have n number of clusters.
Clusters have n
number of projects.
Your projects are where
your applications live.
So we have a number
of different projects
sort of deployed on here.
And if I expand them,
this is an example of one.
Actually let me
do the one in GCP.
This is an example
of one that's running
on one of our GCP clusters.
It tells you the cluster
where it's running.
We can download that
kubeconfig straight here.
And so in this case, we've
got a relatively simple app
and a couple other of ancillary
solutions that are running.
So you've got a Go Backend
supported by NodeJS Frontend,
all running effectively
on our Git solution.
You can tell that because
of the branch names
that happen to be
in the solutions
here in the service names.
And then we've got
an openebs package,
which is actually an
install from a Helm chart
that we've preconfigured.
So now I'll walk you through
what adding a project
looks like.
So I'll click on
this, add project.
And because I'm
super clever we're
going to call this
google-next-demo.
And we will put it on
this Young Forest cluster,
in the default workspace.
So if you're familiar
with namespace quotas,
this is effectively what
this is exposing right now.
So you, as a SRE managing
this, or a cluster admin,
can actually set quotas
on the amount of resources
that you use per project.
So that way any container
or any application
deployed into any
of these projects
can be restricted
by how much CPU
and memory that it uses,
so you don't end up
having one project taking
over your entire cluster.
So I'm not going
to send any that.
I'm just going to hit next.
And then you have the ability
to configure different teams,
roles, permissions.
I'm going to use
the default, here.
So that brings us to kind
of the project overview
screen, where we are able to
actually deploy solutions now.
So I'll walk you through sort of
what that ends up looking like.
So I'll start off
with-- we've got,
again, the three different
solution types available.
We've got our Helm
charts on the left,
we've got our
applications, or Git
push workflow in the middle.
And then our tracker, which is
sort of the adopt your existing
workload functionality.
So I'll start off with
the Git workflow here,
and we will call
this hello-next.
We can define an
update strategy,
because this is largely going
to be a Kubernetes deployment.
So that gives us the ability
to go through and determine
how we want this to roll
out when we do updates.
We can autoscale.
Not going to do that because
it's a pretty simple app.
So that will create
our application.
Where did that go?
What is this doing?
There we go, cool.
So don't what that was about.
Anyway.
So because we're doing
a Git workflow here,
we actually pre-install
a Git server.
So any updates that go to that
Git server will actually--
we'll get an event, and we'll
be able to spin up a container,
and do a whole build
process for that.
So I have, over here, a
fairly basic, but kind of hype
application.
It is a Node.js
application that's
actually using Rust and
WebAssembly in the backend.
So I'm going to go ahead and
add a new remote, which will
let me push up to my cluster.
Do that.
And then I will go push this to
the master branch in this Git
repository.
And so what we've seen is that
this actually has pushed up
updates to this Git server.
And what it has done is this
actually triggered a pipeline.
So we pre-install
Tekton CD pipelines,
which is an open
source project, that's
basically providing
workflow abstractions on top
of Kubernetes.
So what this has
done is actually
triggered a build of creating
the Docker container,
creating the deployment, and
doing the whole build process--
managing all that for you.
So to see that in action.
We can see that we have
one pod that's spun up,
and it has a couple
of init containers,
because that's how
Tekton CD pipelines work.
So this is going ahead
and it's actually
building the container.
It's pushing it to the
registry, and then it's
going to create a deployment.
So while that's
doing that, I'm going
to show you what installing
a Helm solution looks like.
So I'll go back to
our main screen.
I'll add solution.
I'll add a new package.
And one of the things
that we provide here
is a set of prebaked,
effectively, Helm charts
that we've gone
through, we vetted,
that we know end up
working on our systems.
So I'll just install redis.
You have the ability
within the system.
So I'm going to
rename it to redis.
You have the ability to
actually go through and edit
the values.yaml
here, so in case you
wanted to customize the deploy.
You can do that
straight in the browser
before you actually
deploy the application.
So I'm just going to
go ahead and create it.
And what you get is the package
information that comes straight
from the Helm chart.
So that's all basically
part of the package
that is uploaded wherever
it happens to be.
And going back to
our terminal, you
can see what this has
done is it's actually
created a redis slave
and a redis master,
so we have kind of a highly
available solution here.
And so that's just
sort of creating
in the background, kind of
just in the deploy process.
So the third solution
type that we have,
if we to go back to add
solution, is our tracker.
So tracker is pretty simple.
Call this track-app.
All you do is just give this
a series of key value pairs,
to go ahead and track your
deployment or your application.
So for example, you can do app,
equal, I don't know, test-app.
Cool.
OK, I don't know
what that is about.
Anyway.
So that's pretty much the--
I mean you get the
point out of that one.
Cool.
So going back to the
terminal, kind of as one
does with anything
Kubernetes related.
This is actually going
ahead and creating--
it has moved on, so it has
created the redis application,
and now it's running
the node.js application.
So to show that in action,
because I'm not sure
if I want to wait for it
to finish doing its thing.
Show you what this looks
like when it's deployed.
Let's go out to
ye olde internet.
So one of the things we
do here is we actually use
Let's Encrypt to
give you a fully
encrypted end-to-end
connection to your application.
So this is just the demo app--
just Rust and WebAssembly.
Echo--
All it kind of does is
kind of type in a sentence,
in a language, and it
tells you what it is.
So that's pretty much
all of the workflow
features that we've
been kind of working on,
and so pretty
excited for everybody
to start trying
this in pre-release.
So with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Alim to go talk about sort
of all of our data solutions
that powers all of this.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALIM KARIM: Hi.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Alim Karim I'm a
product manager at NetApp.
I'm a product manager for our
cloud volume service offering.
So while Matt and the rest
of the Kubernetes team
have been busy at work
basically deploying
all of the cloud native
application tools
that you mentioned, we've also
been hard at work, basically
building out a cloud
native file services
offering that's high
performance, in partnership
with GCP.
That service is called
Cloud Volume Service.
And really I'm going to
talk about the why first,
why we did this.
What we heard from customers
really were two things.
One was that they had existing
file based applications
and workloads that they wanted
to move to Google Cloud.
So they needed
projects compliant
file services in Google Cloud.
But not only that, they
needed those services
to be highly performant
and highly available.
The second thing we also
heard was for cloud native
applications, being able to
have storage services that
were very flexible,
easy to manage,
and performant, for all of
the stuff that they were doing
for persistent applications
in Kubernetes was another gap.
So with Cloud Volume
Service, those
are really that two use
cases that we're going
after solving for customers.
So that's a little
bit about the why.
So let's talk about what.
What is Cloud Volume Service?
So as I mentioned,
it's a fully managed,
cloud native file
services offering,
that we've built in
partnership with Google Cloud.
And when I say it's fully
managed, what does that mean?
It means that you, as
an application owner
or as a developer, simply go
into the Google Cloud console,
or with our beta release using
the APIs, provision an NFS
endpoint that has capacity and
performance characteristics.
You don't have to
worry about any
of the backend
infrastructure details
to actually deliver
that endpoint.
So capacity planning, networks,
security-- all of that
is really managed in the
backend by NetApp and Google.
You simply, as an application
owner or a developer,
simply consume the endpoint,
with the performance
and capacity that you need.
To show the simplicity
of this, actually we're
running a little short on time,
so that the demo is something
we're going to do at the booth.
But we're actually
running a fun contest
at our booth for people that
have never seen a cloud volume,
don't know what a cloud
volume is, to go spin one up,
and I think the current
record is around 18 seconds.
So in addition to being
super simple to provision
and super simple to
consume, Cloud Volumes
provides high availability
within a particular Google
region, and there's
a set of regions
that we're currently
available in.
But the next big thing
is around performance.
Cloud Volumes enables
a set of workloads
now to run Google
Cloud, that was
previously unable to run, ever.
So we're able to provide
hundreds of thousands of IOPS,
and guarantee those via SLOs
at very, very low latency.
So most of our regions
we deployed a service in,
sub two milliseconds, you can
get for over 100,000 IOPS.
So again, this opens
up a whole class
of applications that
were previously not
able to run on GCP.
Finally, I mentioned this notion
of being built in partnership
with Google, and being basically
a native service within GCP.
What does this mean?
It means that customers
are able to log in
through their familiar terms
with the cloud console,
go into the cloud console
without any other identity
or access management
integration from NetApp-- just
use your standard project
and the credentials
that you use to log
into your project,
discover the Cloud
Volumes UI, or the API,
enable it, and go and
provision your volumes.
That means that there is really
no leaving the Cloud console,
so the whole experience
is very, very seamless
like any other Google
native service.
We also integrate with
Google Service Control
for, those of you that
know that facility.
It allows us to push all of our
metrics, logs and monitoring
data into Google
Service Control.
And so you can consume
that data from Stackdriver,
and essentially monitor what
your file systems are doing,
in terms of performance
availability,
and then be able to even
monitor and set alerts
from Stackdriver natively,
like you would do
for any other Google service.
And then finally, from
a support perspective,
where this is aimed at
enterprise workloads,
so support is actually
provided directly by Google.
Google may escalate some issues
to NetApp in the backend,
but by and large, you know
you as a Google customer
deal directly with Google even
though it's NetApp service.
So I could go on and on
talking about the features
and what it's doing, but
what I really want to do
is hear from someone
that's using this.
And for that, we've
actually got Louis Verzi
from Cardinal Health.
They've been using the
service for a while,
so I'd like to have
him come up and talk
about their experience.
LOUIS VERZI: Hi, Alim.
Hello, everyone.
Just wanted to talk
a little bit about,
like Alim said,
how we came about,
our decision to use NetApp
Cloud Volume Service,
and how our experience
has been so far.
So we have been spending
the last couple of years
doing a lift and
shift migration,
bringing existing applications
out of our data center,
and into the cloud.
We've started with our
non-prod workloads, dev, QA,
and have since moved on
to stage and prod systems.
And about a year ago,
we switched over to GCP
for many technical
and business reasons.
We really found GCP
was a better cloud
platform for what we needed
to provide to our application
teams.
But as we started moving these
stage and production systems,
we realized that we weren't
able to, as we wanted to,
kind of get away from
network-attached storage.
A lot of the applications
that we had out there--
some of them are
COTS, some of them
are homegrown
legacy applications.
They're built on assuming that
they had NAS for providing
high available solutions.
And so we started looking
around for a solution that
would give us the ability to
provision quickly on demand,
not have to sign a PO
with another vendor,
make commitments.
And NetApp met all
those things for us,
so it's been really easy
to provision that storage
and get data out to
our application teams.
ALIM KARIM: Thanks, Louis.
So could you maybe give
us a few more examples
of the types of applications
that you're running,
as well as sort of what the
ramp journey looked like?
LOUIS VERZI: Sure.
We started out obviously
with lower environments.
Our SAP platform
required a place for them
to do their deployments,
do the environments.
We started with that.
We started with some other
low risk applications.
We've since moved on
to production SAP.
We've got our enterprise
content management
that's going to be going into
Cloud Volumes in production
here shortly.
It's been in our performance
environment for a little while,
so we're going to have 20-plus
terabytes of our enterprise
content serving up through
our e-commerce site,
and through our SAP
environment that is going
to be running off of NetApp.
And what was the last part?
ALIM KARIM: The other
thing I was going to say
is sort of, what has
that journey been like,
in terms of using the service?
LOUIS VERZI: The journey
has been very easy.
So the upfront work is just
getting the networking set up,
which with the beta
release, I think
that's going to be even easier.
But really the hardest part was
spending 30 minutes on a call
with the NetApp engineers to
get our networking connected up.
After that, it literally is
seconds to set up a volume.
We always start with
their standard tier,
and if application teams
aren't getting the performance
that they need with
a click of a button,
they can have twice the IOPS.
With another click
of a button, they
can have four times the IOPS.
If they need to grow from two
terabytes to five terabytes,
it's another click of a button.
No restarts, no copying of
storage, no expanding arrays.
None of that complex work that
system administrators have
had to deal with in the past.
So it's really a
very easy solution
that we can put in the hands
of our application teams.
ALIM KARIM: So one of the
things in terms of outcomes--
when you take these applications
and move them to cloud,
what kind of a time
based acceleration impact
do you think having
this service has made,
in terms of executing
those projects?
LOUIS VERZI: Sure.
If we had to refactor
these applications out
of using network
attached storage,
it would've taken months
or years, or longer.
Really, it would have taken
months per application
to get these refactored.
At Cardinal, we've got
hundreds of applications that
are relying on NAS storage.
So it really saved
us years of effort
of having to refactor
these applications,
and it's something that
application teams can kind of
do on their own
time now, where they
can work on getting their
storage into other formats,
that typically in a data center
you don't have access to.
ALIM KARIM: So you
already pointed out
one of the things
that you don't like,
which was that the networking
stuff that we had to do.
And with cloud it's
amazing how much networking
stuff you have to do.
But what are some
of the other things
that you're basically looking
for enhancements around,
that we're releasing in
the upcoming release?
LOUIS VERZI: Sure.
From being in a heavily
compliance regulated
marketplace or industry,
a lot of our workloads
are going to need
NFSv4 with encryption.
Obviously you don't want
to have PHI data anywhere
that's unencrypted.
They're already doing
the encryption at rest.
But we're looking forward to
being able to do encryption
in transit, as well.
The other thing is, DR, that
we don't have to think about.
Right now, we're
using some services
to sync our data
to another region.
It would be great if you could
just, with a click of a button,
have that replication
taken care of,
and then we wouldn't
need to administer that.
And the third thing
is access across VPCs.
So right now, with the
networking setup that we have,
we aren't able to access
data across our VPCs.
But there should be some
solutions coming forward
that'll solve that
problem for us.
ALIM KARIM: Well thank
you very much, Louis.
[APPLAUSE]
So with that I want to
spend a few minutes talking
about what is coming next.
Many of the things
that Louis mentioned
has been feedback that we've
gotten from Cardinal Health, as
well as other customers.
So with the beta
release that we're
planning for the end of
May, essentially we're
going to automate the whole
networking flow that Louis
talked about, give users a lot
more control in terms of which
VPCs, which shared VPCs
have access to the service,
and how they govern permissions
within their organizations
and their service
projects to get access
to these data services.
So if you've got service
projects, GKE clusters, that
are in those service
projects, you
can actually have much
more granular connectivity
into these data services.
We're also going
to be rolling out
Trident, which is an
existing plugin that we have
that will automate the
creation of persistent volumes
and precision volume
claims when you're
running stateful applications.
That will automatically
provision Cloud Volumes
in the backend, and connect
those to your Kubernetes
environments.
And obviously we're going to
be adding more regions here
in the US, in Europe as well.
So before we get into
sort of the questions,
I just wanted to give
the audience-- please
join our pre-release programs.
A lot of these are
driven by, obviously,
conversations and feedback
that we get from customers.
But joining these
pre-release programs
allows you to provide
feedback, and really
shape how we do these products.
Engage with us on Twitter.
Those are the names up there.
Please visit us in
the booth, as well.
We've got most of these demos
and a bunch of subject matter
experts there that can walk
you through the stuff we
talked about.
As was mentioned
earlier, the NVIDIA demo
is coming up at noon.
Is that right?
Around noon.
So that'll be another
cool one to see.
So that's about all
the content we had.
We want to leave a little bit
of time at the end for Q&A,
as well.
And I'll bring Matt and
the rest of the speakers
up for questions.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]